good morning John it's Monday and
nerdfighters if you thought that the
shameless self-promotion was bad enough
when I was doing it for John now imagine
me doing it for me a wall of my CDs
which I have to say you can pre-order
right now any one of these you could get
this one but this is actually just one
piece of a very have to make today yes
the Tour de nerd fighting was fantastic
yes my life is complete yes I need to do
nothing more to do these prison the
planets because of course no criteria is
the best place in the world to live and
yeah I live there thanks to you people
but I do have a fantastically exciting
because news for you all and that is
that me and Alan the stuff olive out of
this dro are starting a record label on
our first release is this new album by
this promising young artist who writes
up funny songs about like Harry Potter
books and Barack Obama it goes on sale
December of 2009 unless you want to buy
the non-physical version of the disc in
which case you can buy it right now
however there are a couple of things
that you won't get if you get that just
because there were some intros and
outros that didn't make sense for the
non-physical disc and also the first
hundred people to preorder it as you
might imagine there's a link in the
sidebar we'll get an autographed copy if
you're into that kind of thing so what
is up with this record label idea well
it is called dftba records
I think the dftba is an acronym that
stands for like digital very simple size
barking animals
dftba things that's what that stands for
correct me if i'm wrong on that one and
the purpose of it basically is to allow
you to related you musician to have a
way to produce and distribute their
music the first person we signed was yes
me but we have also signed some other
very exciting YouTube musicians
including charlie is so cool like
chameleon circuit first band that
focuses yes entirely on songs about
Doctor Who and Dave days who you may
know if you have ever ever been on
YouTube longtime viewers of my channel
know that I'm huge
daddy Simon's we're working on getting
her record album out and we have a ton
of plans on how to make life as a
YouTube musician a little bit easier
little more fun and a little more
lucrative and a little bit more awesome
in general to help people get in touch
with a bigger audience and help a bigger
audience get in touch with these
people's music because this music is
really great and if you want to know
more then you should probably go to
dftba.com that is right dftba.com at
dftba.com you can also sign up for our
newsletter you do that then you sort of
become like a dftba underground awesome
member and we will let you know when
cool things happen because I've got a
couple of plans in the works for free
stuff that I'm going to be distributing
along with my new album like digital
liner notes and maybe a fake book
additionally I should mention that we're
probably gonna be throwing in free
buttons with all the physical CDs that
get bought but the digital CD will run
you a little bit less money because we
won't have to ship it to you anyway that
of my friends has to clear off some news
for the day we've also set up a YouTube
channel we're gonna have tutorials on
how to play our songs we're gonna have
music videos gonna have a weekly podcast
where we talk about dftba records and
our artists and all the cool things that
are going on a new album I'm very
excited and for those of you who are not
able to buy a copy of some jokes on the
tour de nerdfighting now you can finally
get your hands on a digital copy and
shortly hopefully middle of December can
get your hands on an actual physical one
and if you're one of the first hundred
to pre-order then you get it signed and
you may get one of these signed by me
thank you everyone so much for
supporting my music and for giving me a
reason to do this because without you I
would have no reason to write songs
there's no way that this ever would have
existed without you so I can't thank you
enough for supporting me and for
supporting my music and I truly truly
hope that you enjoy with dftba records
has to bring to the world in terms of
our artists and our vision and our
awesome thank you all so very very
say that Voldemort had a son the story's
just begun and I want to hear
that she's bragging okay